it's great to welcome back to the
program Gerald Friedman professor of
economics at my undergraduate alma mater
of the University of Massachusetts Gerry
we've spoken before about your detailed
analyses of the costs and benefits to a
medicare-for-all or other single payer
type healthcare system in the United
States we now have Bernie Sanders's 2017
Medicare for all proposal so what better
time than now to actually talk about
what such a system would cost now you
see the detractors of these systems say
big tax increase incredibly expensive
it's more promising a free stuff that's
not really free the counter to that
would be that it would save much more
money than it would cost so top line how
do we start thinking about those numbers
okay well the first thing to do is to
think about there are actually three
different numbers the first number is
what a medicare-for-all system would do
for the entire US economy versus what we
have now because of course there's there
big numbers involved what we have now a
big numbers 18% of our gross domestic
product eighteen cents of every dollar
that we produce in this country goes the
healthcare now our Medicare for All
system would lower that we would be able
to get the same health care for less
money and this is a point on which I
think there is almost no disagreement
critics will admit that yeah it would
save money on the current health care
system it's almost impossible to argue
otherwise because Medicare is a more
efficient bill payer than the current
insurance systems private health
insurance Medicare doesn't involve the
type of marketing or profits that are
involved in the current system Medicare
saves money for providers because it's
easier for providers to build a single
system than to build the dozens of
insurance companies and hundreds of
insurance plans
in an average American state to give you
just one quick easy example to show this
in Toronto General Hospital in Ontario
Canada with a single-payer system there
are two people who do billing in that
hospital Massachusetts General Hospital
is about the same size the same number
of beds more or less than other patients
there are 450 people who do billing
there I mean so you don't save money
yeah now what about the there's an
argument that part of the savings would
be because if you have a single payer
they could force providers to just have
to charge less and thus it would
significantly depress wages within the
medical infrastructure for doctors and
nurses right how do you respond to that
now they would pay providers less
because providers would have lower costs
because of this Billings is saving on
the billing process and there are some
providers who currently are earning what
economists call rents which is a
situation where you have a monopoly and
you exploit everybody else the biggest
rents are in the pharmaceutical sector
you have this hepatitis C pill that
sells a course of treatments of course
$85,000 in the United States it costs no
joke $200 in India so they are
exploiting the rest of us and the
research for that as for most drugs is
paid for in the first place by the
National Institutes of Health and the
National Science Foundation
so we already paid for this drug and
then we're paying again um so in my
estimates for Medicare for all you'd be
saving large sums on bargaining
effectively for drugs and there were
also some elite hospitals that would be
facing cuts but not that much Medicare
currently pays
hospitals about 22% less than what
hospitals get from private insurance
companies that's overall now that is
about my esta it's a little more than my
but it's close to my estimate of the
administrative savings from single-payer
so yes the hospital some hospitals like
Mass General would probably get a bit
less because they are currently
exploiting the rest of us to some extent
there's abundant evidence on this but
overall hospitals would be wash doctors
would be a wash doctors would actually
benefit those doctors who currently
treat Medicaid patients would get a
raise
so overall we would achieve savings of
maybe six hundred billion dollars or so
on our total healthcare spending and
those savings would largely come from
being more efficient doing the same
stuff better so along those lines along
those lines there was an analysis done
of the proposal that Bernie Sanders had
during the campaign right so this is not
the most recent proposal but from the
wondering during his campaign and it
estimated that the cost to people who
are earning salaries wage earners would
be about a 2.2 percent surcharge which
is tomato Don someone earning $50,000
would be about twelve or thirteen
hundred dollars roughly can you talk a
little bit about in the analyses you've
run sort of what would be the costs to
different parties okay well then we get
to the second and third questions the
first question is the total economy the
second question is the federal
government and yes there would be a tax
increase that 2.2 percent was actually
what Bernie was proposing last year plus
some payroll tax there would be the
federal government would be spending
more and taxing more but that would be
replacing what we're already spending on
taxes that go to private bodies when we
buy health insurance it's mandated by
the government we have to buy health
insurance
and we have to pay for health insurance
premiums to me and to the Supreme Court
that means it's a tax it's just tax
collected by private agencies now the
third question is for the individuals
which who would be paying more who would
be paying less because well overall
we'll be paying less in public taxes to
the government than in private taxes to
health insurance companies because the
whole system will be more efficient but
there'll also be particular savings for
some people because in Bernie's proposal
and in the proposals that are written we
have an element of an income tax or a
tax related to how much money you have
and how much you can afford to pay where
is now your health insurance premium is
either a lump sum everybody pays the
same or sick people or people and
families with a sick family member pay
more so we put a tax on sickness um
which is a double tax in effect because
if you're sick or you have a family
member is sick your earning capacity
goes down because you're spending time
taking care of your family member or
that family member can't have a job
because they have a disability whatever
and then on top of that you have to pay
this extra health insurance because the
health insurance figures out that you're
sick and they put you they get you into
a plan that covers sick people I mean
yeah they have to sell you insurance and
they can't charge you extra pre-existing
conditions but they work it well that's
it that relates to this idea of
everybody with pre-existing conditions
under Trump care versions one two and
three point oh all of which which which
so have so far failed would have access
to a plan regardless of pre-existing
conditions but that's very different
than it being affordable and it sounds
like that's sort of what you're getting
at
yes what we already have is something in
that direction but there are limits on
it whereas what they would propose the
access that's just that's just
I would use a word that you can't put on
television or rush in a radio but you
know access just means they have to
offer you a plan but they could offer it
at $80,000 $150,000 you know and okay
you have access you can buy it if you
could afford it so you and I have been
talking about a single-payer system and
are you experiencing that there are
people who are confused understandably
so not as a criticism between a
single-payer system whereas where the
government would be the one pair versus
nationalizing healthcare where the
government runs and operates the
hospitals and employs the doctors and
nurses do you see as much confusion
about that as I'm seeing oh yes
absolutely this and that confusion is
promoted by critics who say going to
have a government takeover of health
insurance no no no we're going to have a
government provision of health insurance
for people um if you want to buy health
insurance on your own this isn't in
Bernie's plan but it's in a lot of the
plans that I envision um then yeah you
pay out the drugs why somebody would do
that I don't know because they would
already be getting it through the
government um for free in effect because
they'd already be paying the taxes but
there would not be a government takeover
of the provision of health care Britain
has that right uh and arguably the
health care system in the United Kingdom
is the best of the world on government
provision of health care through the
National Health Service is
extraordinarily efficient and delivers
very good care uh but we're not talking
about that we're talking about something
like Canada where they have prior they
have private provision of health care
doctors work independently hospitals are
run independently um but there is
government finance so all the bills go
to a government agency if you go to a
doctor in Canada arm billing amounts to
the following you swipe a card through
their machine the doctor or the nurse
types in
the diagnostic code and the and the
treatment code and you're done that's it
the government agency will send a check
for your services to the doctor the
doctor deposits that check in her
private bank account all them that's it
very what is the best place for people
to be able to check out your detailed
proposals of how this would all work
financially and economically well one
place would be physicians for national
health plan P and H P org on my 2013
financing proposal is up there and
there's a wealth of good information
there top-quality research on the
Canadian healthcare system bar and
healthcare systems issues in the United
States healthcare system there's some
some of my work is up there and there's
a lot of work by other excellent
scholars um also another very good place
for healthcare in general is the Kaiser
Family Foundation kff dot org and
finally the Commonwealth Fund org my
most recent published work on
single-payer was from 2015 for New York
um and that is if you google New York
health plan I don't remember the website
baron arm yeah yeah awesome you know
he's right to me absolutely yes and
people I'm sure will find how to do that
we've been speaking with UMass professor
of economics Gerald Friedman always
great to talk to you absolutely thank
you for having me